Now, let's break down a practical example of how we can take these concepts and build
a typical piece of UI functionality in the Unreal editor.
We can see that we've got dynamically spawned widgets over a world actor, with both procedural
and baked animations.
Their float direction is randomized but their float distance is not.
Let's break down how we've used a blend of code and editor work to achieve this
effect.
The first thing we need to do is navigate to the UI floating damage asset in the editor.
This is under the UI UMG folder.
Let's break down what we can see here.
Firstly, the widget is parented to the floating damage widget.
This is our native class and it's here that will trigger our functionality.
Breaking down the hierarchy view, we can see we've got a single text block inside
of a border container.
We're using 88 as our placeholder text as 88 is the widest two digit number that we
can get.
At the bottom, we can see we've already got a baked, authored animation called spawn
animation.
Clicking through the tracks, we can see we're only animating the alpha of the content
parameter of the border.
This is basically going to take our initially opaque text and blend it out entirely.
Although this looks like a linear blend, if we click through to the curves menu,
we can actually define a different curve between these two keyframes.
Damage text is actually a bind widget, one of the year property specifiers we covered
earlier in this talk.
If we rename it from damage text to a random string, we can see that the blueprint no longer
compiles.
Of course, renaming this widget to the expected value fixes up the binding and we're good
to go.
Moving quickly off to the event graph, we can see that we've got absolutely no logic
at play here, all of our functionality is driven through the code.
So let's jump into Visual Studio and break down the underlying float damage widget
class.
So straight away, there's a few things we can point out.
We've got the usual Uclass, generated.h and generated body macros, meaning we're dealing
with a reflected type.
We cover this heavily in the Introduction to C++ in Unreal talk.
As a brief overview though, we can be sure that the instances of this class are not
going to get garbage collected when they shouldn't be, Unreal's keeping a reference
to them.
We can also see that we're extending off of user widget, as we mentioned at the start
of this talk.
Moving on from there, we've got a couple of publicly accessible functions in our header,
and we'll be using those to drive some of our gameplay.
Next, we're overriding some critical functions as outlined earlier, that being the native
construct and the native tick.
Following that we've got our bindings, that being the damage text and the spawn animation
bindings as bind widget and bind widget animation respectively.
Then finally, right at the bottom, we've got a few runtime members to help us drive
our gameplay.
Take note of the U function markup on the on spawn anim over function.
This is going to be important in just a moment.
Moving over to our CPP, we've got a fairly standard constructor.
Our bindable properties are initialized as null because our design layer is going
to populate those for us, and our float direction is initialized here given a random
X and Y value.
This is how we introduce that random float direction on a per widget basis.
In the body of the constructor, we're creating a delegate binding by passing in both
the name of a function, in this case on spawn anim over, and the object on which
to call that function.
This is why the U function markup was so important.
One of the most useful things about reflection is its ability to find a function by name.
Once this delegate is invoked, it's going to parse over whatever object we pass in
for a function called on spawn anim over.
If it finds one, it's going to call it.
Moving on from there, we've got our native construct, our begin play of the widget
world.
We check to see if the animation has been successfully burned from the design layer,
as it's a pointer after all.
If it is, we proceed through the following steps to make sure our widget both looks
and behaves as expected.
Firstly, we set its alignment in the viewport, and this is essentially going to move the
widget's route from the standard top left to the center of the text, making for
a more aesthetic effect.
Next, we actually bind that delegate.
We call the native bindToAnimationFinished function, and pass in the animation we wish
to bind to and a copy of the delegate.
As you'd expect, when the animation is finished, we're going to get our onSpawnAnimationOver
function invoked.
Finally, we simply play the animation.
So now the widget's been constructed, let's deal with that floating effect.
Firstly, we grab a reference to the local player controller.
If we were on a server, the getFirstPlayerController function would simply return the first connected
client.
However, because we're definitely on the client, calling getFirstPlayerController is
guaranteed to return our local client.
Now that we've got that local controller, we can go ahead and project a world location
onto their screen, giving us a screen coordinate.
In this case, we're just passing in the location in screen space as a ref.
Setting the position in viewport does exactly as you'd expect.
It's going to place our widget over the actor that we're dealing damage to, however
we want to offset that value by some value over time, giving us that float effect.
We simply take that projected coordinate and offset it by an accumulated distance multiplied
by a random float direction.
We'll keep accumulating that value until we eventually get a callback from our animation
that it's finished.
We can see that in our onSpawnAnimOver function, we're simply reporting something in the log
so we can keep on top of things, and then removing it from the viewport.
As the viewport is this widget linked to the root set and the widget is a reflected
member, we can rest assured that it will eventually get hoovered up by the garbage collector
from this point onward.
Finally, we can take a look at those public functions and honestly, there's nothing fancy.
The setDamageValue function simply takes in a float and coerces it into an fText.
Text blocks take an fText type as to afford us a chance to localize whatever text we
want to display.
Of course, in this instance, we're just displaying a float, so we can simply get
away with calling the fTextStaticAsNumber function without having to worry about any localization.
The setDamageLocation function is simpler still, it's just a setter.
The cache damage location is what we'll use in the native tick to make sure the
widget remains over the hit actor in world space.
And that's it, nothing crazy.
We've triggered a bound animation, we've built a procedural animation driven by a
tick, and we've bound to a widget for dynamically setting text values.
Let's quickly take a look at where we trigger this widget's creation, and where
do we take advantage of those public functions.
Jumping into the explosion component, which was a component added as part of the Introduction
to Gameplay talk in this course, we can see our new block of code.
Firstly, we have our NotUeServerPreProcessor.
This means this entire block of code will be stripped out of server builds, ensuring
we don't end up with UI on the server.
This is followed by an authority check to make sure that we're definitely not on
the server, and you'll remember from the Introduction to C++ talk that editor targets
contain both client and server code.
It's important that we have both a preprocessor and an authority check to make sure that
all potential targets are accounted for.
Next, we cache the location of the actor, and check its bounds to calculate an aesthetically
pleasing spawn location in world space.
This value, along with the amount of damage this actor took, is passed through to the
new SpawnFloatingIndicator function.
It's here that we do our actual spawning.
We check to see if we've got a valid floating damage class, and that the amount of damage
passed in was not zero, as displaying zero damage is basically pointless.
From there, we call the templatedCreateWidget function that we mentioned in today's
talk, as well as a sensible outer, in this case it's just going to be the world.
Once we've made sure we've got a valid pointer, we call both the setDamageValue and the setDamageLocation
functions to make sure our widget has got the correct appearance.
Finally, we call addToViewport with a z-value of 1.
Anything with a z-value of 0 or below is going to appear behind this widget, and
of course anything with a z-value higher is going to appear in front of this widget.
We've now got an animated damage indicator, accurately displaying how much damage an
exploding actor takes.
That concludes Introduction to Unreal Motion Graphics for Programmers.
Today we learned about the UWidget and the UserWidget.
We covered authoring new widgets using the Widget Blueprint Editor and its inbuilt
Animation Editor.
We looked at widget-overrideable functions and the special UProperties we have at
our disposal.
And we also learned how we can use the 3D widgets to build UI that can be used in
unconventional projects such as VR.
We wrapped up today's session with a live example of a piece of UI built in UMG, walking
through how we can build UI code that's responsive to designer requirements.
Thank you so much for watching, and have a wonderful day.